- I heard she was in the London gang.
- I heard her brother and
sister ran off together.
- I heard she got thrown
out of her British college
for drug use.
(soft music)
- Hey.
Aren't you that transfer student?
Didn't you get--
- No, no, that's not me.
- Okay, cool.
(intense music)
(phone dings)
- I said no, June.
(sighs)
How is this happening?
(scattered chatter)
I'm so sorry.
Oh my god, I'm such an idiot.
(sighs)
- He likes working too much.
- Wait, is that Bridget alone?
- Bridge.
- Hey.
- Where have you been?
I've been texting you.
- Yeah, I know.
Just been busy.
- Is everything okay?
- Yeah, you can tell us.
- You know, I'm just really
over being gossiped about.
I just want to get along with people here.
- Yeah, sucks.
It'll be okay though.
It happened to me, too.
People don't know you,
so you're an easy target,
and they like to talk, but I promise,
everybody is going to get bored soon.
- Yeah, no, this shit
happened to me all the time
in high school.
My dad moved abroad for work,
and people started this rumor that he
had a secret family over there.
It was so weird.
- Oh, apparently I dealt crack.
I was 14.
- I worked in a fetish club at 16.
Not even legal.
- I ate my twin in the womb.
- I believe that.
- But seriously though,
just like, I promise
this will all pass.
And we know that none of these
things are true, obviously.
Bridget?
- No, there's no truth.
It's all bullshit.
You want to get a drink?
Let's get a drink.
(soft music)